Hey, what's going on?
It's Bill Burr and It's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
March 28th, 2016 the year or the Yak,
whatever the fuck it is in the Chinese new year. I have no ideas.
And that new year. Next, next, uh, next month.
How does that work with those people?
You know how to like, I don't, I don't get it. I just don't,
I don't understand why we're on standard and everybody else's on metric.
Can we just pick one fucking calendar, one unit of
measurement. You fucking go over to Europe. Jesus Christ metric.
And then some old guys talk. Hey, way fucking 20 stone,
20 stone. I mean,
I guess we're still saying horsepower. Jesus. Fucking, well, what size stone?
What are you fucking Free Mason? Um, she buddy in the Illuminati.
Is that where he said, now your little secret group,
you think you're going to make it buying up land on the AUC prefers?
Is that what you're going to do? And then what?
All the robots are gonna take everything over, right? You phase everybody out.
But, uh, except you and then you, you guys, you guys going to be good.
And then all the robots for some reason aren't going to turn on me.
Fucking movies you need to watch before you realize that they're eventually
going to turn on. You stuck out.
You made a fucking robot.
Now it's choking you off with your Dick and you deserve it.
Maddick glad you stayed ban on and later on, there you go.
There was a little Illuminati with a Lionel Richie and you're like that.
Um, somebody sent me this fucking video the way you might want to,
you might want to watch this thing.
And it was basically this person was talking about a,
we showing how the automobile put the horse out of business, you know,
which was so funny to me. Like the Horse was upset like,
Oh fuck you mean human beings are not,
aren't gonna ride on my back anymore guy at what I want. Now what do I gotta do?
I can't run free on the planes. Um, I guess the horse population dropped off,
but like nobody who was no one, you know, most of them are born into, uh,
I guess you really don't see horses running around do you can be on Wyoming.
Yeah. See a lot of cows at the waffle house. I'm sorry.
Well why would you do a fat choke bill this early and come on,
you're better than that bill. Hang on a second. We come on like this,
a certain standard of comedy. You gotta go that low. Yeah.
You got to check the broads and fat people all at the same time, that early.
Hey, you know, whatever, you got to shoot your way out of a slump.
That's my second attempt to get to Cinco.
And this is one of these times I'm recording the podcast.
Not because I'm feeling it,
it's because I have to because I got shit to do tomorrow. So a,
I got to kind of knock this thing out on Easter. So anyways, anybody,
if somebody shows me this fucking thing, so the guys shows how the,
the car put the horse out of fucking business and uh,
yeah, like I said, like, like the horse is upset.
It's like when you watch those weird commercials, we're like a,
the Mr potato heads are sneaking off to eat potato chips.
There's some sort of weird like undertones of cannibalism going on there and
it's supposed to be adorable. I don't,
I don't get those commercials on any level. Um,
but uh, totally lost my train of thought. Oh yeah.
So they were basically showing how computers and everything being automated is
gonna phase everybody out and there's going to be this mass unemployment that is
coming. I'm like, this is fucking groundbreaking thought. I mean,
a dummy like me has been saying this for fucking ever. Right.
And he just kept going like, oh,
see you're in this industry where you're not safe either. You think you know,
you actually, you're a computer programmer. Well guess what?
You're not safe either, buddy. Just fucking relax.
And like he just kept coming with that tone and at some point it was just like,
well, you gonna fucking shine that light in yourself.
That maybe does by the end. I couldn't listen to him. What about condescending?
Douchebags who think they know everything? Narrating over these fucking videos,
you know with your big dude. I called it really our,
is technology in the future going to get rid of jobs? Yeah. I had no idea.
It's only been doing that since the beginning of fucking time and these fucking
people are just forever forecasting that the sky is going to fall.
This is the fucking thing. Eventually the sky will fall.
Nobody knows when it's going to happen.
Everybody's been trying to predict it ever since that fucking Nostradamus
douchebag all the way down to a moron like me.
And the bottom line is none of us know what we're talking about. Oh, lovely.
Mia.
And then on your pocket we'll get a microphone and a in a plug there in the A,
they're in the closet
till the bottom line is nobody knows when all this shit's going to end.
So just get fucking, go enjoy yourself. You know,
I just feel like this fucking, all this whole presidential election you get,
you got one Luna, it's in the cloud. It's on the closet at a top shelf.
You got one Luna tick on the fucking left, another Luna tick on the right,
and then you got this fucking, I don't know what she is in the middle, you know,
she's not really in the middle. She's just more of the same,
you know they're going to wait. They should just wheel her into the White House.
Like fucking handled electric. When I was in fucking mass zone,
he just went up to watch her awful fucking mouth. You need the plug to, oh,
I got the plug over here.
Let me hit pause so the listeners don't have to fucking listen to this shit.
And with that, the magic of the pause button, we were able to get by all that.
Don't you wish you had a pause button in life, Nia? I certainly do.
When all of a sudden some bad was going on. Like, you know,
I was in the middle of one of my long drawn out stories you could do.
I actually want to fast forward, wouldn't you?
I felt that your listeners might need rescuing from that.
I know.
Let me just bring it down because you have an agreement into the mic here. Yeah,
don't do that. Just have it. Just hold it down a little more relaxed. You know,
like you're sitting there with a drink in your hand.
You're always telling me how to use the microphone. Yeah, because you don't,
alright, well fuck can use that. You want to use it then I got my own style,
man. Yeah, you do. Yeah, you don't. You sound sometimes you sound like a fool.
You don't. One of the little kid answers the phone. Oh Wow.
Just pick up the phone. You know? It's like,
hello.
You're like, Hey, what'd you do today? Do you have a good day?
Yes.
That's the hardest thing ever.
I just was talking to my niece and it's just like you gotta like you can't aunt
aunt. If you just ask them yes or no questions, you gotta be like,
what did you do today? He can't be like, did you have fun today?
Cause they want elaborate. Just go yes.
You're like, oh fuck, I needed another question. Yeah.
They're not the greatest conversationalist but oh there they're brutal interview
, brutal interviews. They just think that you always,
that why child actors are so creepy, you know like little kid.
Cause it's like you shouldn't be able, you shouldn't be this articulate.
You shouldn't be able to just like elaborate in a way.
Cause you're a kid. Yeah. Right. Yeah.
No it's, it's a combination that they talk like adults,
they're making more money than you are and they're wearing that little talk show
suit, the whole thing. And they just feel,
and they just sit there and they cross their legs like an adult does when they
do panel and they'll just be like, you know,
so what was it like working on blah, blah, Blah and Greg,
oh he was great to work with. I've, I've, I've been a huge fan of his stuff.
Like I know for the last six years, my whole life basically,
I don't think they should make little kids do interviews. I feel like that,
I think it's one thing for them to do movies and stuff,
but I don't think they should be doing interviews and press and stuff.
I just feel like
that's weird. I don't think people should talk to little kids, period.
Like no legacy, like little kids. I don't talk to little kids like little kids.
No, neither do I. And I think that that is a, like,
I think it weirds them out after the age of four to be like,
oh, okay, you, oh, I'll do both.
So can you like, yeah,
you don't like to remember and remembering young Frankenstein when he just goes
like, yeah,
it is alive. I've never seen it. This alive
Frankenstein sitting, they look looking at him like, dude,
what the fuck is you deal? No. Gene Wilder. Oh No,
he never saw that movie. No. Walk this way. You haven't touched your food.
Are you calling them?
Yeah. Saying words you're caught in the movie and you have a pop cookie.
No, no, like, yeah.
How have you never seen that when we was fucking hilarious at the one where he's
always going Frankenstein. Yeah, cause he's,
I remember those clips but I don't, wasn't there some info? He's young.
Frankenstein with Yahoo serious.
That comedian from Australia movie.
Well God knows I always fuck up the name. It's the one with Jane Wilder and no,
I think you're right. That that's the name of a gene wilder movie.
But wasn't there something with Frankenstein with Yahoo serious? Am I, I dunno.
I don't know. There's like a wind
tunnel where you're, where you're talking like I, you know what it is.
Does it sound bad? No. Cause this is what you do.
You're up here and then you're down here and then you're here.
You're moving it all around. So what do I do?
You need a steady hand on that microphone. You see?
You don't move your hand at all. I'm, I'm pretty consistent. I just,
I arrested like this, I arrested against my chest, my chest nickels. Okay.
So just like my mail, my mail pex here.
My Chester says it sound far away though if I do this. Yeah, it does.
How about this? That's fine. This is good. That is good. All right.
That's right. Then I just don't move and freeze for the next year.
50 minutes. Well, I'm probably gonna leave soon. I just came in to say hi. Oh,
okay. Well, I didn't know if you had any questions from, oh,
that hasn't come in yet. Oh, so where are you going on about Frankenstein?
No, I was talking about the aluminum.
This fucking video somebody told me to watch where it's just like,
this guy's just saying the technology and robots are gonna phase everybody out
and you just go, you know, oh, you're a milkman. You think you're safe.
Check out this fucking robot and everything. It's just like, yeah.
What about condescending dos bags who narrate videos?
Like they probably already have a robot to do that, right?
Don't they? To do what? I'll tell you this to just narrate shit.
They already have the fucking robot lady in the elevator
or even that's just a voice over that. Somebody can slowly please make a poster.
It's like a horror film.
And what did you say that weird robot lady in the elevator.
I want some fucking robot lady in the elevator.
I need to do a poster for a movie with your face looking.
Very concerned and there's like an elevator pressing.
She's in like every fucking elevator and it's like going up.
And then when she says going down,
she goes going down and she really [inaudible] like,
like your whole life is going in the shitter and I can't tell you how many
people,
right. But on the elevator I go, I, it's so fucking depressing. I know.
I hate it. It's not just me. Okay.
You know it's all of us out there in the Ramada, you know,
hoping they got that little waffle flippy thing down there for the continental
breakfast. Those stale blueberry muffins,
those little bite size ones that for some reason give, give you a,
what do they call this? A little muffin top top.
Those things are like little grenades for your gut, for your belly. You know,
you just pop one of those in there and you come like, like homer Simpson. Yup.
Oh, you're going to do this. All right, let's get into the,
let's get into this part of it. Oh, I thought you were giving me Shit, Huh? Yup.
Just doing that shit. Let's talk about uh,
your, your little trashing that you,
you took like a seller level comedy seller level trashing today we were out to
brunch. Ah, your mother in law.
My brother in law, my sister in law and you in Maine and we go out to,
we go out to a launch and you are the biggest sweetheart. You got your,
yeah, wonderful sense of humor. You're a cutie pie.
But when you talk to the waitstaff or just in general,
I still don't see it. Oh, and everybody that was in agreement, you have,
you put a little mustard on it. You have like a,
can you get your shit together or what?
Like how many times do I have to ask you the first time,
like when the lady came over
and she goes, what did she ask you?
And I were sitting down while
while my mom and my brother were outside waiting for my sister.
So we went to get our table and she said, hi, can I get you guys in the drink?
And we boasted waters and she goes, okay, I'm going to get you some appetizers.
And I said, we're just, we're waiting on three more. That's all I said.
But you make it seem like an excuse me. New had this tone of
like, bitch, why would two people sit at a six top?
There's obviously more people coming. You had a little fucking,
and there were menus and they will menus that see there is,
and they were menus and it was totally, that's what it was.
The fact that there was menus there and she didn't do the math.
You just have this, well what the fuck's wrong with you?
I,
but I don't think that I'm a difficult person to serve in a restaurant.
What did you say? That I don't send things
the way. The way that you do it, the way that you do it, it's,
it's one of those fucking zingers. It's a tone.
So the person that you said something nice,
but there's a tone in there that makes a person a step and a half away kind of
cock their head like, well she just being a fucking asshole.
There am I like you are accusing me of being shady.
It's basically what it was and that's not my intention. I just, you do.
You do know though I not shady. Shady is like dishonest.
You're saying that that shady as in I'm being shady the way I'm throwing shade.
Are you going down
and down? Um, I've, I just have, uh,
I definitely have a little less patience than normal perhaps at a restaurant.
This is good. You gradually do feel that? Um,
I don't like it when they're not on top of things. That's all.
And I mean it wasn't just for me,
like my mom got her salad before she got her wine and the rest of us got drinks
and like, you know, me and my brother, my sister all had mixed drinks.
She had wine, like hers should've been the first thing that came out.
And then we all get our stuff and then she gets a salad with no one and I said
to her, and she has a wine to the, when she brought over my mom's fat salad,
I just said she has one.
I wasn't like my mom ordered one and she should've gotten that first.
I don't do all that. No, you don't go to that level. Yeah.
So what's the problem? No, you have a fucking tone.
I can't do it the way that you fucking do it. I just, I always look at you go,
go easy. Nia. Just fucking take a little off your fastball there.
You just had this fucking dude, your brother and agreed. Your sister agreed.
What am I never said. She pleaded the fifth she goes,
I'm not going to get involved in this cause she does the same thing.
To be honest, I'm not trying to throw them off and that's what you want.
That's what your brother said.
What brother goes when your mother would tell I said that's where she gets it
from. Well,
I mean my mom definitely has been known to complain about food.
She bitched about the food in Italy. The funniest thing ever.
She keep saying don't keep
[inaudible] I'm just used to a sandwich that has meat on it. More meat,
more meat on it. No, I mean I think yes.
How hard did we tease her for complaining about food here? A lot. But then yes,
she could support about it, but um, no, I mean my mom has a tendency to be like,
just to the point with people like that because you know,
I just letting them know, listen, this was the Sunday waitstaff,
this was the Easter Sunday weights that like I said, you're not getting,
you're not getting the waitstaff on Easter Sunday.
Like let's be real. Wow.
You're just so you're going in there with that attitude now this is all this
type of fucking predisposed thought and tone that guys like me,
guys like me then offend somebody. Cause somebody did a shift at, no, no, no.
I'm saying on Easter Sunday they're going to say that I'm saying that they're
not the creme de la creme, but if you had been in this restaurant, okay,
so I'm not talking about you. If you had been at restaurant,
you would have seen just how it was a little off.
That's all. And I wasn't like throwing a temper tantrum. Being demanding here,
you have to have mandate.
You have this fucking attitude every fucking place we go.
When you order, you have, I'm always like easy Nia, just easy.
Just all you're going to do. Just pump the brakes a little.
I just feel like they asked me what I want and I just tell them what I want and
what I need. And I'm, the thing is when you order, I think you find,
but then it's when, when everything isn't chomp, chomp coming your way.
You have a way of like, can we get some more bread?
Like please, like you have this, I can't,
that's yes, I lose my page. So you're fucking agreeing with me.
I agree that I have a low patience for
service that is not the quality that I feel this should be.
Yeah. For his. Yes, I'm crazy. I know. And if they fuck with your food,
they're going to fuck with my food too. So it's just fucking,
the waitstaff has an unbelievable amount of power that you're not really
realizing to fuck with your life. I realized that I was a waitress.
Remember, I understand how it all goes down. I just,
and what happened to you at that job?
You got fired and here you are.
I got fired over some bullshit and they could never even tell me why I got
fired. Okay. They were like, oh,
you told somebody that they couldn't have ice coffee. And I said, Oh,
you told me that we don't serve ice tea anymore because it's the fall.
And they're like, oh, but you still can have ice coffee. And I'm like, oh,
I didn't fucking know that.
And that was an example of one of the reasons why they fired me. Bullshit.
It was all bullshit.
It was a little mustard. Yeah.
Little mustard getting slung around in that place. You know what?
You probably have the same fucking attitude.
The same lack of patience with the people ordering those fucking barflies.
Actually, no, you did a great job.
That was one of my favorite times when I was first getting the, yeah,
you should still work at this place. It doesn't exist anymore.
The all state cafe on the west side in New York and she used to work the
lunchtime shift and I would come in as a fucking,
you know no name Magoo comedian. Right. So all my days are free.
My phone's not ringing. You'd come in every day that I was working with.
So cute. You come in with the New York pose, you come in with the paper,
I loved it. And you'd sit in the same booth and you get a burger. Oh Shit.
And I would say Rosa would come by to, Rosen would come.
Joe You looked at adorable. You looked at or people loved you.
Then people that you, you got, you got the shaft there,
which I just brought that up for the shack there cause I had friends there.
But restaurants are just, they're weird environments.
That's the only place you ever got fired from.
And I remember how far you took that because every place else you've just gotten
promoted, promoted, promoted. That's the only place. Yeah, you cried.
So I think maybe that's why you have that fucking attitude when you go in there
because it brings you back and rather, oh, that's ridiculous.
Well then I didn't, if maybe you're just not a nice person,
but now I get impatient at restaurants. I will cop to that. Okay, fine.
I cops are being impatient at restaurants.
Well, do you remember when you were awake weighted waitress and people were like
impatient with you? How did that make you feel?
It didn't make me feel good. Okay,
so the next time we go out,
do you think maybe I'll just let you order from me.
How about that and making all my at school and traditional just like you like
that. Well, yeah, I liked it when there was defined jobs.
Defined gender roles, you mean? Yeah, absolutely. Yeah. Well,
I'll let you had this one made. It made a shrew to deal with.
When you take me out to eat, it made it a lot easier.
What do you mean the questions just came in by the way. Okay.
One of them is skin infection. My doctor,
somebody I'm wrote you about Vega,
they were getting married or they're engaged in their fiance wanting to have a
little mermaid theme wedding. Did you remember this question? Yeah,
yeah cause I got sent it to Andrew sent it to me to, um, it's a comment.
I'm an obviously I'm late, but I just, first of all,
I just don't think that's a real fucking question. I didn't either.
Are you okay, good. I didn't think it was real, but I was like,
if this is real person would really like no 28 year old woman wants,
have their fiance dress up as who was it supposed to be? Nope.
June. Um, you know,
because that doesn't make any buttons sense because June is her fault would be
look a the little mermaids father.
Yeah. I it just seemed like a chill dress
as Prince Eric and the fact that you didn't know that just proves that you lied
because a girl who's really into little mermaid like I am,
would know that those are the facts.
Well, maybe they're just talking about, okay, here we go. Bazaar,
13 most bizarre and unusual wedding themes. All right,
here we go. Look, these people are dressed up like fucking monsters. All right.
Look at these other both dress zombies. Yeah. No, this isn't really,
this isn't good for the podcast. People can't see what we're talking about.
Yeah, well we can comment on it. I can. You have a little faith in me. Jesus.
Stop treating me like a waiter.
Yeah.
Having your wedding at a, at a department store.
These people got married at TJ Maxx. All right.
No comment. No comment. Oh, okay. Your entire party can be superheroes.
All right,
so here this is getting towards a little Neptune or whatever the fuck it was
called. A Little Mermaid. Little Mermaid. Okay,
so one was dressed like wonder woman. The other one's dressed like Batman.
How out of shape is the Batman? It's a loose fitting fucking Batman suit.
He looks horrible. That's some shit that you regret later.
He looks like old Batman. Like you know when your skin loses the elasticity.
Super Mario Brothers can smash it up at your weddings.
That's a wedding cake of Super Mario Brothers wedding.
Just show up naked. [inaudible] okay. Now is this seeing this, this seeming a
wow. What? A bunch of fucking Weirdos. A roller coaster of a wedding.
People getting married on a roller coaster. Yeah,
I could see that jump off for bridge while you say I, do you get the metaphor?
Mia, is they hitting you over the head with the Arrow? Yes.
Uh,
make it so somebody has in their wedding ring to boldly go where no man has gone
before you. This is, this is, he's seeing the theme here. This is Shrek wedding.
Oh really?
Well, anyway, I, I thought the question said that the Dad Yep.
Thrown into a shark cage was not the dad, but like the,
the groom was supposed to be dressed like Neptune and that just would not make
sense unless he was all this comic con shit.
All these fucking nerds try to find middle earth for the wedding of your dreams.
Rocky horror picture show and a Zombie wedding.
I mean, it's just people out there that think that, that shit's cool.
I still thought it was a bogus question. I have. I don't fucking know.
What do I know? Okay. Um,
I was going to tell the story of seeing the old guy fall off the scooter.
I hope we sell it right. Jesus Christ. And you helped him though.
But what was I supposed to do? The first person there,
the daily bird of the rescue fucking guy rolling down the street,
sliding on his face. Of course he fucked up.
He wasn't v at raspberries. He knocked himself out.
He came around and he was spitting up. He was pulling out little bits of teeth.
And I don't know why. It was horrifying when I saw it,
but now I can't talk about it without laughing.
It's just cause he was on a scooter. I had basically I was
on not going to say all the information cause God forbid the people that are
related to them or listen,
it's so the fucking dude was like a Ah, fuck it.
I'll just tell the story. I didn't do anything I had just finished flying.
Does explain is like in tragic, why don't we know his way?
I had just done finished flying, right,
which everybody says is so fucking unsafe. Right.
Fly around and look all this cool shit,
fly over silver lake to see that they took the water out of it and even realize
that. And I came back, I fucking land, you know,
say goodbye to everybody and I'm driving out, you know, to the real scary thing.
Driving down the fucking street and I literally pull out,
I make a right turn and I don't,
I don't drive more than 40 yards and I just see this fucking guy,
just this old guy takes the turn to come onto the,
on the little two lane highway that I'm on,
he's on the opposite side of the road and he like,
he went too fast and I'm like a motorcycle. You can't just turn the front wheel.
You're going to go down on a scooter. You know what I mean?
You've got to kind of look your way through the turn and lean and your momentum
momentum, you know, it's supposed to look through the fucking turn. He,
he was going too fast and he went into the fucking island in the middle of it.
Bell, he fucking jumped the fucking curb.
The whole fucking scooter went up in the and you high sided, right.
He just gets launched off this bucket thing and he's rolling down the street
like a fucking log. Why are you laughing so hard? Cause people falling down.
It's fucking hilarious. He was fine. He didn't break anything.
You just knocked himself out. He's a little because,
and then he wasn't wearing a shield and in the end he was sliding on his face.
So I'm going, Oh shit. Oh Shit. Oh Shit.
As I'm watching it and I fucking pullover. No,
I made sure everybody stopped and I got out. I was like, dude, dude,
I just stay there. You're all right. You're all right. And um, and he was,
he wouldn't say anything and he has fucking raspberry on his face.
His pants were torn up.
He literally got fucking attacked by a wild animal and he's fucking late.
I feel terrible that this happened to him, but it's just afterwards,
it's just funny. And he was laying there right in like one of his legs.
He had like up, like he was chilling and the LN was just straight out.
Like that is as like that. And he was like around and I was like, Oh man,
I called nine one you find, you find,
and then this lady shows up and she just kept going, don't move. Don't move.
Okay. You're okay. Just don't move. You should have to keep going. Okay.
And it started annoying me and I almost started laughing like,
I want to be like, lady,
like the way you're talking is probably worse than what the fuck is failing
right now. So, uh, by then, you know, like five or six people had stopped.
Everybody called to this ambulance shows up like, okay, thank God,
and now he wants to get up. And we just kept telling him not to get up.
And um, the ambulance pulls up and he just goes, uh, he goes, does he all right?
Is he all right? You're like, yeah, yeah, he seems to be okay. You know,
we're not fucking doctors, but he seems to be okay. And he goes, all right,
just tell him not to move. I already have someone on this ambulance,
there's another one coming and then he gets the ambulance and drives away. Yeah.
And then we're looking down the street and we don't see any ambulance come and
we're like, what the fuck? And um,
finally one at a cop finally came up and this guy was fucking priceless.
He gets out right? Fucking horseshoe bald guy. Right.
He's got the whole land in strip.
He just comes out looking like Sargent Riker from the rookies for anybody's old.
Any fucking just comes walking. He looked, the guy from MIP blue,
the old guy showed his ass with the mustache minus the mustache.
She just comes walking up and he just walks right up to the guy, Dennis frons.
Yeah.
He just walks up like his toes are almost touching the guy's body and he just
looks down at Amigos. Yeah. All right.
Okay. And the guy at that point is going like, yeah, yeah, I'm fine.
And he goes, I know Daniel's going to be coming. Like he just,
his level of just like [inaudible] and he must be like,
people would be on fire every day. So this guy,
he just sees a scooter and this guy fucked up. He just like, yeah, yeah.
All right. He also seemed way too old to still be in a patrol car.
So I think he fucked up somehow and got busted down.
Or maybe he was on his way to some, uh,
senior police fucking banquet or some shit. And he's as I have,
I'm driving the cruiser. They know I'm a cop. I have to stop.
So once that was fine, it was funny,
they were just standing there waiting for the ambulance. But you know,
we gotta get on with that day and uh, me and there was this tall,
older black dude standing there and this, he's just like that guy,
man right here. And I was like, yeah, the heat. And we just
both got in a car and fucking drove away. And uh, it was really, you know,
it wasn't too bad. I mean, it wasn't too glorious scene.
It was just a couple of raspberries and stuff. I didn't have a,
but it was serious injury. Oh yeah, absolutely.
But it wasn't until I got on the highway and I started driving.
I started thinking about it and I just started laughing.
I think it was just more than surprise that you saw it,
but there is just something
just watching somebody get fucked up like that.
I remember a time I was in Griffith Park and that dude came down the hill in
street clothes on a skateboard. He went down that fucking,
what are you serious dude? This kid hike. Will you hike up to the observatory?
Somebody was going down. Yeah. Escape War. Yeah.
So I was just north of where the Greek theater was and this guy just went flying
by and this thing and I was just like, oh my God,
that guy is the shit like, and I'm thinking like, well how's he going to stop?
Cause this is just downhill to you get into traffic and all of a sudden his legs
started doing that. What are the Dah Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah.
That wobbly fucking thing. And I'm like no fucking way.
And I'm telling you this guy was going 30 miles an hour.
Then he just steps off the skateboard.
You always do that either one or two steps and then you're done.
He was going so fast, he did like one step and it was like,
who's that guy? Oh fucking jump 30 feet,
1969 nobody ever broken he fucking head first
flying. It was like the greatest study of his side. And he landed too.
And he started rolling. When I tell you this guy, this guy was rolling so fast,
he was like a blur. He's like, here we go. Like you hit like his elbow,
which would shoot him in the area.
Okay.
That the the best is when you're not going fast enough to keep rolling and then
you just slide in the same way all the way down the thing. And now
it was skateboard kept going and anyway, and he just,
he was just not moving and I was going like, oh my God.
And he was so he started wiping out like 50 yards away from me and I swear to
God I was a quarter mile walk to get where the fuck he stopped.
And he was just laying in the road, not moving. Like I was like fucking dead.
He had, he had no helmet. I had street clothes on.
He looked like he just came back from drinking and he just had like this
Harrison Ford, like Brown leather chair. He just fucking launched himself.
So I get up, so I'm getting close to it at this point. He's trying to set up,
he knows he's laying in the middle of the road and I finally seen his skateboard
hit the curb on the other side, balls into a parked car and then he like,
like crawled. He tried to stand up and he couldn't put any weight on like,
and he crawled,
he crawled over and sat down and by then I knew it was all right.
So I was already starting to laugh, so I was just going like
doing that dude while laughing. I go, you are right. He goes, he's like,
yeah bro.
And at that point I'm trying out the lamp. I was just like, dude, I go,
that was fucking, it was fucking hardcore, man.
I never seen a wipe out like that. If I was filming that fucking thing, dude,
it was the most fucking, it was the greatest log roll,
whatever the fuck you call that thing. That dude was just
[inaudible].
I know senior that I can't believe these shoes stayed on. Like, you know,
your shoes always fly off whenever you get hit real hard. Yeah. Oh my God.
Tremendous. Fucking tremendous.
And it's just as much as you feel for the person,
that's just nothing funnier than watching somebody fucking wipe out if they
don't die and you don't know him. Right. God, God, help me man.
Anyways, let me do a little podcast radio for some, uh,
for some of the advertising. Oh, it's advertising time. It's advertising time.
You do the question to actually ride. Yeah.
I can get right to those things if you know, I just don't want you to start,
you know, talking to me in a certain way.
I was going to ask you what you wanted for dinner.
I'm starting to get hungry again. Um, something remotely. Oh, here we go. Oh,
the advertising and wanna help me read some advertising you had.
God knows I can't read out loud. They don't want me to read it. Well,
I can't read this again. And she had the whole fucking,
am I supposed to read the whole menu? I'm not doing this shit. All right,
you're supposed to look at it before you do the podcast to be me.
I didn't get into this business to have a job. Blue Apron,
everybody. All right, you need to know how to cook. Um,
not only do you feel like you know your way around the kitchen, honey,
but cooking at home means eating healthier and saving money instead of ordering
expensive takeout again. But where do you start?
It sounds like an almost old school infomercials.
Somebody's like looking at all the pans and looks at the camera and shakes their
head. Look, I don't know where to start. You turn on a burner.
You fucking jerk blue apron,
blue apron as you covet for less than 10 bucks per meal.
Blue Apron delivers all the fresh ingredients you need to create home cooked
meals. Just follow the easy step by step instructions.
This is actually a cool thing. This is what I would definitely try that.
Can blue aprons and awesome. No. Oh, okay. Neil,
we got too much shit. I'm trying to get rid of shit.
I don't need a bunch of beltway friends hanging around.
They send you food and a recipe card or you know, I haven't even finished this.
That's what blue apron is. What are you talking about?
How do I know what this is? You're doing the advertising.
You don't know what Blue Apron is.
They send you the ingredients and then the rest of they suddenly the exact
amount you need so you don't buy too much or too little.
Well then they should call it blue recipes, shouldn't they?
Maybe you do want me to read it.
Each meal can be prepared and I'm just saying if I was young, right, and I was,
you know, dating or anything, that is a great way. Let's stay in tonight. Whoa.
We're a little blue paper. We can do that.
Each meal can be prepared in 40 minutes or less.
No overwhelming trips to the grocery store. Oh wait,
no more sad takeout. Oh, look at the noodles.
No matter how. I love what they just have to shit on everything else.
It's convenient. Why do you have to take grocery stores down
no matter your dietary preferences?
Blue Apron makes it a breeze to discover and prepare dishes like I am not
reading all of these fucking things. At least read three. Let's,
we'll do like a little like a Donny and Marie here. I'll read the first one.
Chicken Fried Chicken with what?
Have you not heard them. Chicken Fried Chicken. You have chicken fried steak.
Oh, chicken fried chicken with baked sweet potato and quick collared Greens.
Oh look at him. Go shrimp.
Poboy sandwiches with Tribeca bread locked in.
The fuck is striped back a bread. Maybe we should go to blue apron.
Dot Steak and it for ourselves. Steak and eggs with Kimchi fried rice.
That sounds good. I love Kimchi.
It's spice catfish with Paez direct style rice and Creamy Saffron Aly.
Ooh, I used to be my stripper name.
Seared pork with sprinkler. Such an old jokes. Don't,
don't turn off the a computer knock. Kamado come on, I'll look.
You'll hear a radishes and sugar snap peas Hash with ranch yogurt.
I haven't heard after the show. One word. Oh, radishes and sugar snap peas.
Hash and I guess, yeah, Hash with ranch yogurt. Yeah, I speak the language.
That sounds great. In your own kitchen.
Cook with ingredients that you've never used before. Like watermelon, radishes,
Pharaoh, Pharaoh, Pharaoh, Pharaoh and purple potatoes.
Appliques with purple potatoes. Oh, we need to go to the farmer's market.
Oh yeah, like every Sunday. And it was all those dirty people walking around.
Dirty people are just, you know,
you're talking about the vendors and all the lefties.
Even talking about like the hippie farmers guys,
all the man bonds to the fucking hair falling into the fucking Kimchi.
That kind of plays the way you could definitely buy a weed there and not,
I actually, I don't mind the farmer's market,
but I hate how you have to get there. I just hate that. Hey,
you got to get there early. You got to get the earliest like, do I,
let me just go down the street and I'll just get the poison.
Oh and recipes between 500 to 700 calories proportion,
delicious and good for you right now, you can get your first two meals for
free@blueapron.com slash [inaudible] that's [inaudible] dot com slash burger
blue apron. A better way to cook. Actually,
I like farmer's market because if they actually are local farmers,
I like to support them,
but I know the corporate food has worked its way in there. You know,
they just take off corporate potatoes and they just write, hey man potatoes.
And then it's like me by him thinking I'm sticking it to the man. Hey man,
potatoes only two this week near. Can you believe it? Great.
I read these things. Helen's a great group. Uh,
right now it's not helix helix. Was that the name of the group? I don't know.
Give me an r.
O c c j what are you talking about?
What you want to do? Rob Do Rocky.
You don't remember that song now? It was like a, I dunno what it was.
It was one of the most bizarre things and there was some reason they would dress
like fucking, man, that sounds like an eighties thing. Oh, absolutely.
It was an eighties thing. You know how old I was in the 80s I got what?
I don't remember. Sorry. Yeah, but you know other things.
We're speaking of robots taking over everywhere.
How can you have a can make a robot do what James Brown did? You can't.
You can't. You know what?
But there's some fucking nerd trying to insert oppression in pain into a robot
to see if they can give it a little bit of soul.
It's like x Mash. They start treating it worse than the other ones.
Yeah, or ex machina or however you pronounce it.
It's like Helix night after night. I really feel like it's helix. Helix night,
half tonight. Two people lay in the same bod [inaudible].
It's bed night after night. Two people lay in the same bed,
but when it comes time to buy a new mattress,
only one gets their way until the end.
The fucking top until now.
Introducing helic sleep Helix Helix,
where you can buy mattresses online,
customized for both of you for hundreds of dollars instead of thousands.
Go to helix, sleep.com.
Answer a few simple questions based on four key preferences.
Do you pee the bed is a real question. Um,
when you jerk off, are you on the couch here?
Do you need a plastic so-and-so mattress cover?
As a result? You know this, that's why they're so cheap.
These are old mattresses of bedwetting.
I'm keeping it entertaining.
So listen to the rest of the information they know that's not true until now.
Introducing Helix sleep. Well, you can buy mattresses online,
customized for both of you for hundreds of dollars instead of thousands.
Go to helix,
sleep.com answer a few simple questions based on four key preferences and the
results will be custom sleep accustomed sleep profile use to build you the most
comfortable mattress you'll ever sleep on.
Your mattress will arrive at your door door, door, door in amount a week,
and shipping is 100% free. And for couples. Hey, helix,
customer's customer, I don't know.
Each side customizing each side of the mattress,
personalized to sue each of your bodies and the way you both sleep.
He looks customizes customers' report,
a 30% improvement in overall sleep quality. How do you gauge that?
You're asleep, right? So when you wake up,
you know whether you've had a good night's sleep or not. Alright, fair enough.
You have a hundred nights to try it out. If you don't love it,
they pick it up for free.
And then what do they do with it and give you 100% refund,
no questions asked. Gross. And then what do you do?
You throw that back into the rotation and one of the only a couple of hundred
bucks. All right. Hey, just fuck on this side of the bed.
She likes it more soft. She likes it.
You have a hundred nights to try it out.
That's why everyone from GQ magazine to Forbes are all talking about helix sleep
. Yeah. Yeah. George Clooney has one of these.
Go to helix.com/bar and get $50 off your order.
That's helix,
sleep.com/burger Haley's sleep.com/bar I like the idea of having a mattress
that's tailored to both of our sides. Look,
if you just want to sleep in a different bed, just say it all right. No,
I don't think so. No, of course. All right. Do all his shave club.
Joe Dollar Shave Club Dotcom has this special offer for new members who join
today. You get a free month kid of the executive.
Raise it when you buy a tube of doctor cabbies. Dr. Chavez. Easy Shave.
Bada um, what Dr Carver's.
Oh, say carbs. Yeah. Dr. Carver.
The carvers I've been saying Carvey the whole time. Dr Cavities.
I started to carvers. I never noticed that until optic.
Calvin's easy shale.
Okay.
Dr Carver's shave butter is what it's called. Easy shave butter.
That was a little too fucking, I don't know. Well, what do we make in here? Huh?
What are we making here? I put this on my face. You share about that.
This is the first time they've ever done something like this,
and once you try dollar shave club.com you become a proud member like millions
of others.
One reason is because they deliver amazing razors right to your door for a third
of the price of what the greedy razor corporations judge.
That means when you join dollar Shave Club,
you could afford to shave with a fresh blade anytime you want one want,
which feels fantastic,
you'll get a first-class shave when you use the executive blade without hurting
your wallet. Another reason is there,
doctor kv shave butter carver carver using it with the executive makes the blade
glide gently for the smoothest shave ever, ever.
Dr Carver's shave butter, is it your average shave cream?
It's a unique conditioning formula with high quality natural ingredients,
leaving your skin feeling unbelievably fucking smooth. All right, we get it.
And right now, new members who buy a tube of shed the shave butter,
get the executive razor for free. They've never done this before.
Take advantage of it.
And it's only available by going to doc dollar shave club.com/bar.
That's dollar shave club.com/bar hey, dollar shave club,
cut.com/bar oh yeah, it's tough.
It's tough.
That's why I fuck around on him because I'm not going to have people subjected
to my fucking reading out loud without, you know, if it's a funny train wreck,
like the way I read is like me watching that old guy fall off this scooter.
Oh grandpa grampy did you take it too fast? Hey, guess what?
My Boston Bruins did teeth today.
Did they do something that's going to put them in the running to be in the
Stanley Cup finals? Uh, the playoffs, the playoffs last week, you know,
we will fucking, possibly could be a, you know, a bunch of shit had to happen,
you know, basically the ranges in the capitals had to keep losing or whatever.
And we could've gone past them,
had been in first place in the eastern conference and then we lost five in a
row. Okay. And today we, uh, we won our first one PB Toronto.
Thank Josh and breweries. Yeah, it was going to be a shit show.
We lost five in a row. We fucking lost a San Jose, Anaheim, the kings,
then the ranges and then the panthers and the wheels will fucking come and off.
And then, uh, of course as always brush around and shower fucking step up,
you know, for the, uh,
I guess the time gold and then the ahead goal and what's his face? Bless.
He got the fucking empty net or I missed the whole game cause we were at Brunch
and I was sitting there watching you looking absolutely gorgeous.
Treating the white staff in that way. You didn't want to go to that?
No, I didn't know.
I didn't want to go cause I thought your mom wanted to go to someplace where
everyone was going to go and everyone was going to show up with their Easter
hats and I was gonna be standing out in the sun with,
it's going to be a 45 minute wait.
If you guys want to go down the street and get some drinks and then maybe come
back, we'll give you this vibrating square. Yeah. And I don't want to do that.
And not to be that. No, it ended up being great. Ended up being great. Oh,
by the way, I haven't even talked about it. Yeah.
I played the terrorist state or last night in Long Beach.
The place where a Richard Pryor did the greatest stand up special of all time.
I want to thank everyone that came out. I had such a great time,
but for the first 10 minutes I was literally freaking out going like that's
where he told the white guy, you know, sit your ass down. You know,
this is where he did. My monkeys died and I remember in the end when I waved,
good night, I remember how he finished the set,
doing the woman having the orgasm and the whole place goes nuts and eating out
to say goodnight. He just waved. Ah. I started to watch the special,
I had to stop watching it because I knew it would fuck up my set,
but like it is,
if it is the definition of a comic who's just in a zone,
he walks out from the beginning to end.
It gives me like fucking goosebumps when I watched that special. To this day.
He, he's the greatest. It's not even fucking close.
And I got to basically stand and do stand up and I just can't believe I've
watched that specialist since I was a kid. And,
and you walk in and it looks the exact same where you drive in is where he drove
in with his wife when they filmed the special and it all still looks the same.
And as I was walking in, I was getting like the chills and you just walk in.
It's like, there it is. This is, this is it, this is the place. And,
and at the end of the show, when I said, good night,
Dean del Ray came out and out, showed me in the spotlight,
went on him so it wasn't on me. And so it wasn't in my eyes anymore.
I could just see the spotlight hitting the tops of everybody's heads.
And that's the way I saw the theater, you know,
cause they didn't really show the crowd in that special. And, um,
it was just one of the coolest things ever.
And then the night before I worked at theatre in Riverside, California,
that they actually debuted, gone with the wind. The first, you know,
before they had the official premiere at Mann's Chinese theater,
they wanted to make sure the sound was out right.
So they just headed east and they, uh, they shot at, I don't know,
they fucking whatever.
They played the movie out there and I got to stand on those stages and it was
fucking tremendous. And I want to thank everybody who came out. Um,
it was fucking amazing. It was fucking amazing. Yeah. Um,
and lastly, before we get into the questions is the, uh,
the Lincoln Continental. All right. I talked to this, you know,
this guy who drove us,
we've got a driver to take us down to long beach because I knew it was going to
have a couple of whiskeys after that. You know, I was trying to be responsible.
So, um, you know, I, I was sitting there going like, you know,
I liked the Lincoln Continental. I hope they don't fuck it up.
I hope they make it fuck with the Mercedes Benz. You know,
like those really make this a nice car. Like fuck with the seven series BMW.
I went to seem to be a nice fucking car and I was saying it'd be cool if they
actually brought back the suicide doors and the driver was going, yeah,
they're doing that. The top of the line. One's going to have suicide doors.
And I went and I looked it up and here's a picture of it.
How sick is that fucking car? That's very cool. Um, we're,
I'm gonna post this picture and it's just the concept car. And as far as I know,
they didn't fucking do it. Why wouldn't shit do that?
Look at that fucking pew that it's the second fucking shit ever.
Yeah. Look at that car. Yeah, I see. No, it's cool.
I'm looking at, hopefully you guys had just,
you're looking at the picture right now.
They even have like the trunk comes up and slides forward and then the bottom
kicks out and they should fucking luggage. You can see it in real life.
They can.
We know what you have to do is you have to buy the car and then you got to take
it to one of these wizards out here and say you see that? I want you to do that.
One of those gas monkey guys. T tell him to fucking do that to the car.
Wait, what's this one though? I saw on the bottom this, this is a Lincoln. Yeah.
This is what the led lights and in this one, the led lights like the,
the Lincoln continental,
their emblem also lights up in led lights as fucking sick. That's nice.
2017 Lincoln continental to replace 2016 Lincoln MKX.
Yeah. I'm either going to get that or I'm going to get that dodge Ram,
our t s sport, like just the two door. No extra cabinet or that I just,
I'm such a Ford Guy,
but I just fucking love the way the dodge Ram Hemi truck looks.
One or the other. One or the other. But I'm going to get some,
I'll probably get the old man car. That's me. Right?
You're definitely an old man. Oh yeah. God Damn it. You know, but again,
I thought it was cool. I guess I'm like, all right, so here we go.
Unless they fucked the car up and then I'll be right back to square one. Um,
look at this fucking guy.
Okay.
It's like, wait a second. You are addicted to Worldstar hip hop like this.
Go watch these videos. Constantly do this. The funniest shit ever. So sick.
His fights, the funniest fucking videos. And then there's all this,
all this rap shit that I'm never gonna fucking, I'd see that I,
I'm too out of the loop.
And I ended up seeing like I was the guy I liked to Trinidad a yes to Trinidad
James James. Yes. The fucking, that guy's a genius. I don't know.
So fucking G. Yay. Yes. He's totally different. You don't think he is.
I've enjoyed a couple of his songs, but uh, whatever wouldn't go that far.
You didn't see the fucking video where they had the things in that either the
coolest shit they did that in the fucking, the openings of that movie belly.
This is not like a new concept. Look, everything's been done.
You could do that to my echo. Are you being, yeah,
he's treating everybody like a fucking waiter this week.
I'm trying to give somebody a shout out who got fucked out of a record deal.
You know what I mean? You know? Unbelievable. All the,
I get to criticize shit. I see that. All right, let's get onto the a,
the scope of the, uh, let's get to the questions here for this week. All right.
Daredevil dear Billy. Nunchucks uh, you know nunchucks are yes.
Bell.
That was it right there. That was it right there.
You just asked me if I knew what nunchucks I just asked you.
Yeah. I can't even read out loud. I'm not judging you. Fuck.
All right.
Last year someone recommended you to watch a daredevil.
I would like to reiterate that a year later, season two is the shit. Uh,
the punisher fucks people up the way he should and you actually believe the love
story. Tons of cool fight scenes. Watch it with the whiskey.
Not sure if Nia would love it, but this one's, this one's for you. All right,
I'll give it a shot. I heard it's really good. Well, let's, let's,
let's watch it. Let's watch it tonight. Okay. We'll watch it.
You want to have a whiskey with me, sir? Whiskey with old, frisky over here.
Um, sorry. Skin infection. Oh,
the question everybody has not been waiting for. All right, dear bill,
I was hanging out with this girl and I think she gave me a quote.
Skin infection. Oh No, I haven't been with anybody else.
I confronted her about it and she said she didn't have any symptoms.
I am 100% sure I haven't been with anyone else. And I contracted it from her.
She's acting like nothing happened. And I didn't say I got it from her,
but it's still kind of weird.
Should I take my chances and get back with her or move on?
What kind of skin infection they have
means STD. He's just trying. I know. Okay. Um,
I was hanging out with this girl. I mean if you are,
if that was the only person that you had slept with in like the last six months
and you didn't use protection and uh,
I mean as long as you told her just get treated and I mean that's up to you if
you want to keep paying in this girl or not, but um,
don't keep banging this girl. Yeah, probably not. Especially if she,
I mean cause the thing is she could at least be like, all right,
well let me go get tested just in case.
And then you can both be tested for everything and get treated for everything
and that's all good. Yeah, go your separate ways.
This is how this thing starts off. Yeah. It's not good.
He obviously likes bagging or otherwise he wouldn't be asking this question.
It must not be too many prospects on the horizon.
If this is what it's come down to
and I'll, I'll go the obvious one. She's really good at fucking that.
She's done it a lot. A lot of people I may maybe May,
well maybe she got on and maybe she got unlucky. Maybe she just had the gift.
I don't fucking know. Geez.
Well I hope whatever you got is hero section. Go to the doctor and get treated.
He is protection. Like don't be an idiot. Stop raw dogging out here.
Okay. New Girl. No new car. Sorry. New Car.
That was like a Freudian slip. Like get a new girlfriend.
Get the fuck out of that thing. Oh Man. Dude.
Ah, that's brutal. Makes you happy to be married. Alright, new car.
Dear Billy Blue Book.
I'm in the market for a new car like yourself.
I want to get something used, something with character,
but my girlfriend thinks I'm holding onto the past and I'm trying to be hip in
my own way. She wants me to get a facade.
What do you know how much of a creepy sell out I'd have to be to drive a
pesticide out. Your thoughts? Sexy car.
Why would your girl want you to get [inaudible]? That's some lame.
I would want to see 30 man car. Not a fucking facade.
Keep all them a Japa plus that.
But I also fucking drive an eight year old dented Prius. I know, but you're,
I mean I'm a frugal son of a bitch. Yeah. I think it's a little bit different.
Why? Why is that different? Well,
you didn't tell me to get the fucking thing what it is.
You know what it is out there.
There's so many fucking men and women out there that that will derail your
fucking dreams. Okay.
I wonder if she wants him to get a car like a paisano cause I feel like that's a
reasonable safe car because she's trying to get you to save up for a ring or an
apartment or something. Yeah. Look at that thing. That is not, oh my God.
That's as soulless as my praying ass car I've ever seen in my fucking life.
That is so blind. Yeah. Free isn't Lee's. It's like,
what is that a Poseidon? I don't want this. Whatever.
I'm horrible in the fact that Germans made that Germans usually fucking crush
it. Well then I'm sure it's very efficient.
Leave that one alone. Um, but other than that, I'm not into it.
I think the bigger thing here is what happens to a lot of people when they get
into a relationship is, look, there's definitely going to be some compromises,
but like when your heart's fucking racing and you want to fucking do something
or the person you're with and you can see it like this is something they want as
something of a passionate saying,
something's gonna make them happy for you to try to fucking talk them out of it.
Like, why would you do that? She wants some rain. That's why.
And she's trying to get him not to spend,
I have to spend money on an older car that needs repairs and need this and that
and the other when he could be saving for a ring. I guaran fucking see it.
That's what you're thinking. I absolutely think, well, if he gets a used car,
isn't that cheaper than going out and getting a new Passat? Uh, what,
what is it? I'm, what do you want to,
I want to get something used and then with character,
but things I'm holding onto the past and trying to be HIPAA Myoma.
[inaudible] having a little bit of style plastic car he must've plastic to means
you have something like that. She wants get upset, right?
She wants him to get a nice cost effective. Moderator, she is.
We're going to have a family and a house someday. A car.
That's what that's about. Read. Read in between the lines.
Read in between the lines.
I thought she was the dream catcher. You know Jane Catcher,
Jane Catcher is like your dream and this is my dream and then she catches it and
she puts it in her pocket like a dream killer. Dream killer. Right?
But you've got to catch it first
just so it's like an ant. You can't kill it much.
You just decide that things are what you want them to be.
That a dream catcher is really what a dream killer is,
but you have to catch it for catch you first. Catch it before you kill it. Okay,
honey,
I live in my own little world over here. All right, magma,
magma. Okay, dear bill, have you heard,
have you heard about the lonesome blues or have you heard of magma?
I just saw them in la.
They definitely sound like some sort of fucking metal band here.
I'd never heard of them,
but went with a friend of mine who works in post production.
The drummer is 68 and unreal. All right. I already loved this band.
He plays a combination of Jazz and progressive style beats, tons of soul.
The music is interesting and operatic. He invited his,
he invented his own language and it's really out there.
Please look some up and give your reaction on the podcast. Well,
let me fucking do it really quickly. We're running out of time here.
Let's see here. What do you think? You think you're gonna like it, man?
Well, I'm curious about it. I'm surprised the dude I went to,
I went and I saw this crazy fucking band,
Bobby Lee's Bobby Lee's brothers in it,
and I went and I saw this crazy fucking band like, I don't know.
I got to the show late. I can't remember the name of the band,
but they'll fucking Ho. Yeah,
somebody tagged me in a picture you took with one of the band members.
I had the best time.
They had this once to look them up so you can give them a shadow. Okay.
Okay. I had the best fucking time. All I remember was the fucking,
the closing song was,
was that the guitar was like really like thrash restaurants and the guy just was
going like, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no. Was, it was just so ridiculous.
It was awesome and funny and I was just going to let you should put that on an
album cover and then have all the lyrics like written out like, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no. Oh, they're French. Oh, they are magma.
The weirdest band in the world. All right, let's, let's see. We got here.
[inaudible]
all right. I'm already in. I kinda like it too. I would go see that.
That reminds me of the vibe out to this kind of stuff you always reminds me of.
I used to go see, I used to go see Oz noy down in the village. Who? Mas NOI?
[inaudible]. O. Z. N. O. Y. Yeah.
He used to always have like will Lee would be down there and Keith Carlock would
sit in and you said all these insane drummers. Um, look at him.
Oh my God. Oh my God. Yeah. I love it.
They all look a little long in the tooth. The actually,
these guys are all beasts. That guy,
the bass player looks like the cop that walked up to the guy in the fucking
scooter. Yeah. All right. Oh my God. I love these guys. Um,
I'm man, let's speeding up. Oh, what's going to happen?
[inaudible]
hang on. Why can't leave you here? Here we go.
Let me fast forward so you don't have to sit through all that.
[inaudible]
dude, I would just, this is the, yeah, this is when it's asking weird.
It gets all fucking night. Yeah, I'm in, I'm in. No, I feel like if there was,
if we had our own version of the Andy Warhols factory or something like that,
like a big loft space downtown where we just had a bunch of our artists friends
and assorted Weirdos,
we can have magma playing in the background and it just would make a lot of
sense and we are,
yes you could drown out all those assholes that hang around with people like
that.
I'm not an Andy Warhol fan on on any level or you don't like his like persona?
No,
I respect the originality of it but I also just feel like a lot of it was smoke
and mirrors and it was very like that hipsters sort of sort of the rich God,
the original of like that hipster shit.
Like am going to paint a soup can and like it's some sort of comment on
capitalism and everything and it's just like, all right,
but is it a really a deep comment on it because it's not moving me.
I Dunno. I mean I like Andy Warhol, I like his stuff.
I feel like that was a very cool time to be in New York City during that time.
I feel like I would have loved to been a part of that scene, but, um,
it just seemed to me like it was a bunch of nerds trying to be cool,
pretending like a lot of hipsters to me.
I think there were a lot of misfits that found each other and they created like
their own little world and they became cool because of that.
That's what I think. All right. Because there's a bunch of like, you know what,
I'm transgendered people and just like, yeah, come and you,
and they're just automatically cool. Right?
They're just automatically cool and you just listen to what I'm saying.
Like there's no asshole transgendered people.
Can I explain to you what it was?
The bringing together all these different kinds of people and that was different
in New York City. It was like a whole birth of interesting,
like outsider perspectives and giving them like a platform and like you're a
freak and you're cool. No, I absolutely think so. Then like the, the uh,
what is wrong? Why can't, why if I have a different opinion,
you gotta fucking get upset. No, it's not that you have a different opinion.
Is that you literally didn't even let me finish my thought before you just
hopped on that whole thing and that just makes you,
I interrupt what I do. Fine.
You're taking this way through Searcy. Look,
do I have any sort of artistic style of looking at me like I'm in a buffalo wild
wings. I'm going to sit here and criticize fucking Andy Warhol I,
Oh yeah. I took an on Elvis cover that somebody else already created.
Then I painted red and blue stripes across the Warhol. Could it vary
easily made that poster. That's the kind of stuff that he made.
Actually there is a poster of him and John Michel Basquiat.
That was kind of like some poster. Yeah,
like the kind of like battle of them boxing and stuff like that poster could
100% have been what? Andy Warhol date if you were famous back in the day.
That's all I'm saying. So you're saying it's not original.
I'm saying the person that did that perhaps is not putting a head on something.
Was he the first guy that he was the first day I was Photoshop shit style to
that poster, which is really cool by the way. And like that's,
it reminds me a little bit of what Warhol might have done.
That's all I'm saying. All right, well what,
we even went to a museum though, like, let's be honest, if I don't like them,
I really don't like it. Look at Princeton. If it's a bunch of old cars,
if it's painting old cars, if it's paintings, a cars, you know,
there's a big debate actually in the art community are automobiles works of art
and they,
and they took a Ralph Lauren's car collection and they stuck it in one of those
fucking stuck up museums there.
Moma or whatever the fuck it is. Museum of natural history. The, the,
I don't think they put it in the museum,
the fucking losing her on day vote on Fifth Avenue,
whatever the fuck it's called. Every other fucking broad. I dated in New York,
that was always the first date. Like they, oh, let's go to a museum. It's like,
will you stop back and look your smart stop doing this just cause you're dumb.
Does stop trying to find abuse. Oh for fuck sake.
So let's just go out and get a drink and see if we can deal with each other.
I got to go fucking sit there and stand next to you in silence.
Reading Shit above dinosaur bones. Yeah, that sounds like a lot of fun.
I'll meet you there.
Um, no I don't like them. I don't like,
one of the worst museums I ever went to was when we went,
we were in Vatican City and we should have gone to the right just to look at
that overrated painting on the fucking ceiling. We went to the and said,
can we just pause and I just ain't know what I'm talking about.
They know the Sistine Chapel, so fucking overrated.
The art that was in the Madigan, like this art,
that's like a hundreds upon hundreds. I'll tell you what now, like this amazing,
if I bought that building Oracle fucking art,
if I bought that building the Sistine Chapel,
I would turn that into a cigar room and I would let that smoke go right up into
that overrated. Do they make it seem like it's fucking huge?
There's no way it took that long.
Did bill
there and you looked at it for like five seconds and then you were like ready to
get a fucking Panini. Oh Shit. Yeah. I'm going to tell you. Take him.
I'm gonna fucking guy. You know what he was?
He was like the original contractor. They said, hey, can you paint my ceiling?
Yeah. Yeah. This will be easy. I'll have this done in like three fucking weeks.
Fucking four years later. Yeah.
They're fucking the green pages on back order.
He's got 20 other sealants he's fucking working on.
Um,
you can't tell me when you went through the whole Vatican thing and you watched
every fucking vestment that every God damn pope war,
like after a while you like, I get it.
They all wore these ponchos with a cross on it.
I was fascinated by it because I love religious art. Okay.
What about sexual assault? What about a fucking 800 pound gorilla? What?
Did they have a little something about that in there? Yeah,
cause I kind of went, yeah,
well that would have ruined the year while it was an art,
the way they hit all those pedophiles, all those years.
That's an art form and be moving all those chess pieces around while still
collecting the money and not paying taxes.
What does that have to do with the art that we're talking about?
Saying at the Vatican? Well,
if I was to talk about a certain somebody Sitcom right now,
I think you would bring up some of his offstage behavior.
Are we talking about Cosby? No, we're talking about fucking slappy.
Right?
The priests, the ones that were painting the fucking Sistine Chapel Bill. No,
I taught, I'm not talking about that.
I'm talking about when we looked at every fucking fork and challenged that Pope
John Paul the fucking 58 when you go into the Sistine Chapel,
which admittedly I thought was this 16 chapel. Did you really?
You don't remember that we have staying alive. Remember I said,
you know what I would do, cause this line is so fucking long. If I lived here,
I would open a bar across the street and I would call it the 17 chapel.
And you're like, why would you call it that? I was like 16 chapel,
the 70 chapel. And you just looked at me and your eyes narrowed and you said,
Bill, it's the Sistine Chapel.
And I said, oh.
And that's my story about Rome.
Okay.
Alrighty. Fuck all you guys. All right. 37 years old, ladies and gentlemen.
Let's see what, well yeah, I'm not into that shit. Okay. You know. Okay.
See that, look at you. You're an angel. You can see through my stupidity.
You don't have to be into it. I still love you. It's, you know,
good guy is still, you know what?
But the reality is that there are certain things that are common knowledge.
I really should have known that. I would think so.
But I bet a lot of people think it's the 16th chapel.
You know something I don't, uh, I don't like,
I don't get embarrassed by shit like that.
You really don't know if I think I would. Yeah. Yeah. I thought it was the 16th.
I didn't know it was this thing. And then everyone, oh my God, it's assisting.
It's like, did, is anything in there from something that you created
then shut up. What are you, oh, that was the Apollo 13 mission.
Oh really? You will fucking astronauts.
It's just sitting in this diner with me getting fucking eggs, aren't ya?
And they're not the farmer's market once either. That's why you don't like the,
the museums.
Do you feel like there is a pretension in people who like art and stuff like
that? It's too much fucking shit.
It's too much reading and it's reading. Oh my God.
Ain't just keeps going and going and going. And then there's people whispering,
I got like this up here to see this day.
That's what happened to me in this,
in the Sistine Chapel when we walked in and I was just like, oh wow.
It's kind of small. Anyway.
Oh,
oh,
I want to put that guy's head right through the fucking stained glass window.
We were in a church, so it's like a holy place. So you know, you got to keep it.
Why we think they went on a certain level of noise to drown out the children's
screen in the basement. Oh my God. They deserve it. Fuck them. Pieces of shit.
Um, we can't, we can't end up in that.
Why isn't the dog coming in here? I'm a little concerned. Oh,
play out because she's a low Oh, poor thing. She's right there,
right baby. All right. That's the podcast for this week.
I'll check. Get audio. She was sleeping on Thursday.
What's that? Oh, she was sleeping. Okay, cool. All right.
She was just sleeping well, thank you for Ra hanging out on the podcast.
Thanks for having me, man. All right. I'm glad you came by.
I don't think those stories of people falling off shit would have been as funny
and somebody to bounce it off of. Oh, look who's here. Sleepy old gray bear.
Yeah. Our seeing your dog. I know. We just realized that dog's is senior now.
She's eight, she's eight and a half years old.
Starting to get a little bit of white and her face. Yeah.
That made me sad and it made me happy. You know,
she had a rough first year and a half when she's just been fucking chill and
ever since a shit cleo.
She looks great though and she's still adorable.
She's still our little baby no matter what as well.
I think she had to pay rent at this point. All right, that's it.
I'll talk to you guys on Thursday and once again, seriously man.
Thank you to everybody that came out this weekend. Uh,
those tests are scratching the shows, um,
at Riverside in a terrorist theater.
And I want to thank Dean del Ray for crushing it both nights. And um, that's it.
I got Canada coming up later on this week. I'm going to be in Ontario. Um,
you know where Ottawa and a bunch of places. Um,
I think Windsor, I have no idea. They're all on my website. Um,
I'm bringing ah, Jesus old Jesus.
I better hit the fucking treadmill cause I'm bringing fucking the pride of New
Jersey. Paul Versey and the, the godfather of the Rosebowl tailgate,
Joe Bart, nick himself is a, he's gotta be coming along too, and, uh,
it's going to be a killer fucking show. All right. That's it.
I'll talk to you guys later.